[Applause]
cyberpunk is an interesting one the
20/20 world is a fusion of many types
and elements of the overall cyberpunk
genre and it's about a combination of
technology gone wrong but being used by
people in novel ways up against large
mega-corporations powerful people and
powerful forces governments etc that are
all pretty much conspiring to keep
people oppressed and stomped on it's as
who's once described in somewhere is a
craptastic world
we have a lot of amazing technology but
that technology can be used by gangs by
corrupt officials by cops by create
cyborgs running amuck so it's basically
if you took some of the almost a Blade
Runner and amped them up to 11
actually they line up really well part
of it is the fact that they dragged me
out there quite often to sit and talks
in the entire studio about how the world
works what makes it tick what was I
thinking when I did certain things so
they don't just do that with one studio
I've visited all the studios at some
time or another and we sit down and we
talk about it we talked about okay so
what did this particular thing in a
world mean what is how does Arisaka work
what sits really shifted Milotic how do
people live day to day and all those our
discussion points on the table as we
kind of Ed shout where we want to go so
the resulting project looks a heck of a
lot like what was in my head
[Music]
actually it wasn't as much of a flash
and I'll tell you why I'd seen it two
weeks earlier and so there I was and my
son Cody works for Tel saurian as well
as a designer he was with me and we
watched it and we went ja you know
dropped mind blown but we could tell
anybody you know it was that secretive
we literally snuck into town to do the
e3 show everybody snuck into town it was
subtly funny because nobody likes to @cd
blow the surprise we want fans to see
something and go oh wow if they get
spoilers all the time there isn't that
hey I just discovered this cool thing oh
yeah already knew about that yeah
whatever so yeah it I actually had seen
it so I was more impressed actually by
how they rolled it out the entire
hijacking of the conference it which was
just brilliant I kind of knew they were
talking about it I just talked to the
marketing guys they said yes you like
this but actually what was done in there
I'd already seen the basics of it before
and I went yeah and now by that time it
was like okay yeah it's just gotten
cleaner it's gotten tighter and for me
it was exciting because I went and I
happen to know that this is game footage
this is not something pretty they build
this is the engine you know and I also
had another advantage i dollars also
seen with you know some some glitches
and things because it was still way to
heck back there I'd also seen gameplay
I'd actually seen it run seen it on the
ground as a work
when we did cyberpunk originally the
genre was pretty new and so most people
didn't have a clue as to what the genre
was about or what you could do and
that's why we went through and in my
design I explained what classes did so
that people would have a context in
which to place their gaming characters
so out of that we got characters out
fairly obvious solos for example are
essentially muscle and guns for hire
they are combat hired people who
especially is delivering force at the
right time in the right place for enough
money base in my sword for corporations
they oftentimes will also work for the
guy on the street depends on the job
depends on what is necessary but the
flip side of it for example is rocker
voice rocker boys personal favorite are
more than just people who get up with a
guitar and play I like to think one of
the prototypical rocker boys might be
bono from u2 in that the music that u2
is writing is political it's meant to
get people up and in the streets it's
meant to expose corruption and
difference problems that are happening
every day so it's music with a challenge
what a rocket boy doesn't have to be a
musician a rocker boy can be anyone who
say orator of the people anybody who can
talk to others and convince them by the
power of words music sometimes art and
so forth yeah it is a bit mad max I love
Mad Max but oddly enough the biggest
influence was my friend Walter John
Williams did a book many years ago
called hardwired and hardwired one of
the major characters is a Panzer boy
which is a guy who basically does
deliveries across a post-holocaust
wasteland in a fan tank and I asked
myself in a world that's gone to hell
no one's gonna have fed exed anymore
no one's going to have easy movement
from place to place so nomads are more
than just Mad Max Jews with Mohawks
leather rolling down the highway they
are basically the people who get stuff
moved from A to B whether it's on the
ocean well there's not the water whether
it's in the sky and they have a very
very dangerous occupation because it's a
world that doesn't want to them to do
this or wants to steal their stuff
han Solo would have made a pretty good
nomad
interesting enough net runners we ended
up with something a bit different
originally and this is because I hadn't
actually read any William Gibson's work
at the time and I first started writing
this I only had what Walter had written
and ideas I had began to put together
because I worked in software and net
runners are effectively I think of them
as a combination of the thieves of the
world and the information brokers of the
world they go in they find stuff but
they find it within a network and the
net in cyberpunk is more than just
floating icons out there and you know
bright colors it's an information
structure that these guys are very good
at digging around this is actually
becoming more important since an event
we did with cyberpunk many years back
called the fourth corporate war when the
net was pretty well torn up the net
runners are the only people who could
actually start find out what happened to
the financial records what happened the
information who really ran the world so
net runners in some ways they're almost
digital indiana jones' as well as
thieves
what happened was before I met CD
Projekt RED I started cyberpunk read and
it was essentially going to take the
timeline forward from the events of the
fourth corporate war which ended a
period at 2027 and it was going to move
things forward I did a version of it
called cyberpunk v3 which was like a
what-if story
think of it as a side story but I wanted
to continue the main storyline because
you guys probably noticed we move the
timeline forward you know we started
with 2013 we moved forward to 2020 2077
wrapped that timeline then we're gonna
move forward from the 30s into the 40s
and 50s
ok as it turned out we always have a
dominant color scheme in projects we do
and we had done a green color scheme in
v3 so I said hey I'll do this one in red
because of the black and red combo that
were known for so it was nicknamed
encoded cyberpunk red and that's the
name and then something like six months
later as I'm banging away on it you know
my business manager comes in and says
hey there this guy's name CD Projekt
that want to talk to you CD Projekt RED
total coincidence what it's about pretty
much is moving the timeline past the
fourth corporate war and one reason we
refresh the timeline and alter things is
that at a certain point the players have
mined out all the possibilities of the
existing part of the timeline so they've
gotten all the biggest guns they've
gotten all the apca armor they have all
the enhancements they fought Saburo
Arisaka to a standstill
you know the whole bit so what we do is
we change things up
so the fourth corporate war was
deliberately designed to scatter all the
possibilities of the wind technology
disappeared or reappeared or moved in
other ways or became more like a
treasure hunt
we wanted to explore what
happens when the fundamentals of a
technological society don't get
destroyed because there's just too much
of it but they get seriously messed up
so for example we blew the net apart but
you're still gonna have cellphones and
limited Nets because all those routers
and all those cell phone repeater towers
are round somewhere but you're not going
to have the net reaching across the
entire world so you'll have Micro nests
you'll have cellphones at work within a
city you'll have specialized phones that
go beyond that you'll have all the
weapons you had but there'll be new
weapons that have been created or kit -
together because there's no longer US
military came out Milotic handguns so
the idea was to make it more of an
exploratory world to expand things a bit
me on Knight City to tear down some of
the assumptions and allow players to
find a whole new way not to play the
game but to explore the game and the
great part was then with 2077 there's
this really nifty span of time between
where we are in the 30s all up to 77 and
a lot of stuff can happen in that period
and that's still kind of it's kind of
loosely like that right now I don't
think we've any of us have entirely
decided where that sits yet you know
obviously they have drawn tremendously
upon 2020 and they're popping up with
things all the time it was fun looking
for example at the skyline in the
trailer and just pointing out all the
different things that were obviously
part of the earlier 20 20 rev mm-hmm yep
but there were a bunch of new ones and
my Mia thought is okay where do those
guys come from and how does that work
and does it go all the way back to 2077
all the way through to 2027 you know
what's the continuity that part we're
still kind of working out
you know like I've said it's it's always
in process because you have a lot of
really smart people and they have
something they love they keep
experimenting they keep finding things
out
you
you